[Aplausos]
eu sou publicitário eu passo boa parte
da minha carreira criando histórias
histórias normalmente para tentar vender
alguma coisa que você provavelmente não
precisa comprar para sobreviver
eu não vou falar aqui sobre isso hoje
mas eu queria começar também contando
uma história diferente dessas histórias
que eu crio minha profissão é uma
história que você precisa comprar para
que ele sobreviva e não ela não é uma
ficção
eu nasci gay de novo eu nasci gay eu não
passei uns o ano da minha vida sem ter
que houve uma agressão desde que eu me
entendo por gente
a [ __ ] dói linha [ __ ] até um ponto
que se passou a ser natural para mim eu
apanhei aos 8 eu apanhei ou 9
eu apanhei aos 10 eu apanhei o 12 pelo
simples fato de existir
eu torci muito para que a puberdade
chegasse porque imaginava que essa voz
grossa que apareceu essa barba esse
jeito um pouco de homem só que não é
verdade ia mudar um pouco as coisas
aos 18 apanhei de novo foi a pior de
todas as e ainda consegui fugir de uma
tentativa de estupro que aconteceu
dentro de um shopping como esse não é
disso que você gosta seu [ __ ] até
hoje eu não sei como eu consegui fugir
daquele mata leão
aquele mata-leão por outro lado ele
nunca mais fugir de mim eu rezei todos
os dias para que deus me fizesse normal
é claro que isso não aconteceu
então eu tentei me consertar pelo
caminho eu namorei um monte de mulher eu
me machuquei muito por isso e
consequentemente eu acabei machucando
pessoas muito queridas anos depois eu
finalmente me senti seguro de seguir a
minha verdade a minha sexualidade
e seguir em frente sem jamais poder
deixar de olhar para os lados como
precaução
essa história pode parecer distante da
sua realidade mas ela aconteceu aqui
mesmo no nosso país no brasil que não
por acaso é o país que mais mata lgbts
no mundo todo o mundo todo não distante
de você também nessa cidade em são paulo
que não por acaso é a cidade que lidera
esse ranking nacional e que foi palco de
um dos mais simbólicos ataques
homofóbicos se tem notícia de que tem
memória no país que é o ataque da
lâmpada na avenida paulista
acho que todo mundo lembra disso com
bastante pesado e aí eu pergunto pra
vocês
você já imaginou como é passar uma vida
toda fingindo ser quem você não é uma
vida toda não poderão expressar o seu
sentimento em público com medo de
apanhar ou até morrer e principalmente
seja para pensar para onde vai todo esse
silêncio que você sente dentro de você
quando você não pode dizer o que de fato
você pensa o que você sente
para onde vai esse silêncio essa é uma
pergunta que vinha à tona na minha
cabeça o tempo todo é pra onde eu estou
levando esse silêncio que está aqui
dentro dessa história
até que um dia numa madrugada na verdade
num dia de janeiro desse ano eu estava
dormindo acordei pensando sobre isso
porque é uma coisa que recorre muito a
minha mente eu falei tá como eu posso
transformar todo esse silêncio num
barulho alto o suficiente para que
qualquer pessoa possa me ouvir
eu levantei da cama peguei um papel na
caneta e comecei a escrever a letra de
uma música eu nunca tinha 30 uma letra
de música antes na vida mas ela
simplesmente aconteceu ali na minha
frente
são coisas que acontecem que a gente não
consegue explicar eu estava muito
ansioso com aquilo eu sou casada e meu
marido acordar ele acordou foi assim
cara favor leia aqui a ele leu olhou e
falou assim ah mas é um funk
eu falei sim isso é um funk e digo mais
eu vou gravar esse funk
eu não sei nem dizer o consultor foi
assustador na relação
essa história vai dar tudo certo estamos
aí
três meses depois aquela aquele silêncio
transformado numa letra de música tinha
virado isso que eu peço desculpa pelas
crianças que estão na sala mas eu vou
apresentar para vocês um clipe
[Música]
o fervo também aluna o leão
passar na calçada espalhando o terror
sol da mão segura firme chega o fiscal
já morrer todo mundo tá ligado
a queda é bahia disse cuca quebra
lambada na cara pra não existia na boca
e chama de [ __ ] invertido em baixo
todas pixinguinha bolinha rancho paola
quero muita atenção porque eu vou falar
pra tudo tem que ser macho pra [ __ ]
pra poder é o próprio eu apanho na
paulista imagina na rua ela não cai na
real mas de pé do lado dela lindo
planeta na igreja não vai ter pra tua se
joga na pista de rega prata fato eles e
fui ver se me ama ouvir esse m é só pra
tua mina que tu gosta de que o théo
rodrigues destacou cheio então tu me
respeite
um carro a tua boca enche logo ela
janeiro
[Música]
yang beijo é ligado por incrível que
pareça é a mesma pessoa
ainda estranho pra mim até hoje olha
fala assim cara mas como dizia o velho
teve coragem mas sim é que é um termo
que acompanha a identidade sexual e
identidade de gênero há muito tempo né
será considerada uma palavra
completamente pejorativa significa
estranho esquisito inglês e ao longo do
tempo foi adotado pela comunidade lgbt e
hoje ela é um guarda chuva então
qualquer pessoa que não se identifica
como como heterossexual pode ser um
quilo e é por isso que escolhi esse nome
para representar o mato de densidades
possível e não sei só mentiu
é a máscara do hemiciclo e foi o que eu
tive que criar para conseguir fazer isso
honestamente ao mesmo tempo em que ela
representa vão poder colocar o caso do
microfone mas ao mesmo tempo que ela
representa é a máscara que todos nós
lgbt vivemos todos os dias para
sobreviver
ela também protegia um pouco isso e dava
mais espaço pra isso né eu queria que
minha voz e a mensagem fosse ouvida
mais do que esse rosto ficava na frente
como um cantor era esse o objetivo
eu nunca tinha é encantado na vida nunca
é no dia que eu escrevi a música no dia
seguinte eu liguei para um amigo meu dj
o maestro billy só na casa do campeão eu
falei cara tem um projeto ele achou que
estava completamente louco no primeiro
momento mas ele entendeu o que estava
por trás desse propósito ele se
prontificou imediatamente me ajudar
ele foi o primeiro sim que eu recebi de
muitos inscreveriam pela frente
inclusive de algumas pessoas me emociona
muito então essa platéia é esse sim
foram fundamentais para que esse projeto
acontecesse
meus amigos meus colegas de trabalho
seis colegas trabalham os dois chefes
meus é no amor
todo mundo se uniu para fazer esse
projeto aconteceu eles entendiam quanto
isso é importante para mim
enquanto falava com a minha alma eu tive
que dá vida ao hemiciclo para tirar esse
silêncio que existia aqui dentro que me
incomodava tanto e eu escolhi o funk
como veículo porque ele já é um estilo
que tem um histórico de empodera
minorias pensa no periférico pense nas
mulheres nas bonitas nas valesca
danificaram as maravilhosas que foram
integradas pelo ritmo e também porque
tem uma capilaridade gigante no brasil
né ele fala com diferentes classes
sociais
ele fala com diferentes idades eu achava
que era o veículo ideal pra é fazer e se
esse projeto e aí
lançamos esse maio a música foi lançada
já 15 de maio exatamente dois dias
depois eu acordei com essa notícia
fiscal em primeiro lugar nas 50 músicas
do brasil no spotify
foi um choque
ao mesmo tempo fiquei muito contente
porque eu falei assim encara a mensagem
está sendo espalhada por outro lado eu
falei assim que eu faço agora porque
isso aconteceu de um jeito que também eu
não esperava
e aí de repente uma música virou uma
música eo clipe que vocês viram a música
eo clipe de repente estava no top hits
da mtv e aí a música creep top sante
virar um disco de sete músicas do disco
de sete multas virou uma versão dessa
música do clipe inglês que foi lançado
nos estados unidos na europa para passar
a mensagem lá também e aí eu perdi o
controle porque na hora que eu me dei
conta eu tinha uma vida dupla de 2ª a 6ª
eu estava no escritório tentando nos
fazer você comprar alguma coisa que você
não precisa nos finais de semana eu
estava no palco do no palco eu estava
ajudando pessoas
visão de fato de ajuda para sobreviver
porque todo esse projeto é um projeto
beneficente 100% dele ainda da música do
clipe é da venda da música de qualquer
show ele beneficia projetos e ongs que
cuidam de algum direito ou tratam de
algum tema lgbt que eu escolho pela
região onde eu tô fazendo show
principalmente ligado o projeto ele foi
incrível ele saiu de maneira muito
fluida parecia que ele tinha que
acontecer que tudo deu certo mas ele não
foi tão fácil assim como parece para mim
foi difícil lidar com ele
eu apanhei de novo por conta desse
projeto de dentro e de fora da
comunidade lgbt de dentro porque a gente
tá vivendo um momento de desconstrução
de verdades muito importante e pelo qual
não tinha passado ainda a minha
realidade é de homem se gênero branco
gay e as verdades são múltiplas e é por
isso que esse palco é tão importante
aqui hoje eu aprendi muitas outras
verdades com esse projeto por conta das
críticas que recebi sobre ele porque as
pessoas acharam que eu fui muito
simplista maneira de passar essa
mensagem
mas foi uma escolha eu achava que tinha
que ser simples para atingir mais gente
pensa o chiquinho que atinge de verdade
eu não fiz esse projeto para ser o herói
dos games
eu fiz esse projeto para ser vilão dos
homofóbicos
é para eles que essa letra escrita isso
deu certo porque se eu apanhei da
comunidade lgbt
eu apanhei infinitamente mais fora dela
de um lado porque um dos principais
problemas do mundo a falta de empatia é
claro você não vive a dor é muito
difícil você entender a dor e muita
gente achou que eu estava fazendo esse
projeto passando vergonha está passando
vergonha com esse projeto
isso me fez pensar uma coisa que mudou
completamente minha vida eu tava
passando vergonha e eu pergunto pra você
uma coisa que mudou de fato a maneira de
pensar sobre
a minha atitude com relação ao mundo e
as linhas a importância que eu dou para
as coisas no mundo pensa sobre essa
frase um pouco pelo que você está
disposto a passar vergonha para pensar
sobre isso porque a resposta para essa
pergunta é exatamente a causa pela qual
você deverá estar lotado na sua vida e
eu estou disposto sim a passar vergonha
pra que nenhum outro lgbt têm aqui se
esconder
apanhar e morrer eu vou continuar
passando vergonha cuidado e é claro que
eu apanhei também dos conservadores né
dos guardiões da moral dos bons costumes
da família ea gente tá vivendo uma onda
no mundo de conservadora muito nociva no
mundo todo e essa onda trouxe ao
hemiciclo ir de agressões verbais a
seríssimas ameaças de morte com nome e
endereço pra mim e aí eu queria retomar
a história que contei pra vocês lá no
começo você entender um paradoxo que é
inerente de ser quem somos
eu não faço nada a respeito disso
eu apanho porque eu existo eu tento
fazer alguma coisa sobre isso é o apanho
porque eu luto
difícil né mas eu fiz uma escolha
eu prefiro viver uma vida de luta do que
correr o risco de viver essa vida de
luto
obrigado obrigado de verdade
obrigado de verdade